as an academic I care that I learn
something every day if a day goes by I
don't learn something that's a wasted
day and ideally you should get your mind
blown at least once a week by just
something whoa I never knew that and so
for me that is how I establish and
derive meaning in my life hey hey and
welcome this is the Ben Shapiro show
Sundays special I'm excited to be joined
today by Neil deGrasse Tyson his brand
new book is letters from an
astrophysicist he of course also hosts
star radio which is a podcast and his
famous show cosmos on National
Geographic
Neil thanks so much for stopping by
thanks for having me so why don't we
start with for folks who don't actually
know your background before you became
famous scientist person who talk science
well what exactly is is your background
how did you get from where you were to
being who you are I I just like learning
about the universe ever since I was 9
years old they first visit to my local
planetarium the Hayden Planetarium but
grew up in new york city and i had the
advantage of well the city offers the
advantage that for many of the cultural
institutions once if you do sort of the
exhibits and the front line things you
can do a deep dive and at the American
Museum of Natural History which is the
sort of the overarching institution that
has the Hayden Planetarium there were
courses I could take there were special
sessions I could attend and so it wasn't
just the space show and an exhibit I
could continue to probe the structure
and nature of the universe right from
middle school on through high school and
that served my interest like really
really well I went to the Bronx High
School of Science which if I may counts
eight Nobel laureates among its
graduates which equals the country of
Spain which to look that one up that's
kind of crazy and I went up to College
majoring in physics I have a PhD in
astrophysics and this this
public stuff is really it just happened
to me it's not like I was seeking it out
I still not seek it I still just want to
stay in the lab but what happens is I
realize that there's a hunger there's an
appetite for the universe out there or
there's an appetite for people who are
in search of meaning in their lives and
religion has served that role for so
many others who are not religious or
even if you are people look up and just
wonder you know where do we fit in this
unit we everyone's looked up right maybe
if you live in the city and you look at
me just see buildings but between the
there's sky and it's part of what we are
as humans you know we're one of the few
animals that's completely comfortable
sleeping on our backs just think about
that maybe your dog can do it right but
the dog is completely domesticated so
they're not worried that some of the
animals gonna eat their guts out while
they're asleep you could so I wondered
whether in the earliest times and we
sleep at night so we sleep on your back
in at night and if you wake up in the
middle of the night the sky is there
think about if you're only facing down
and you're asleep you have no
relationship with the sky so so one
night you see and then like the planets
are in one configuration and later on
they're like in a different commune so I
just wonder whether curiosity about the
night sky there's something that runs
deep in our DNA so in a second I want to
ask you about the quest for meaning
particularly using science because I
think that there's a rich conversation
obviously to be had and you talk about
it a lot in your book letters from NASA
physicists but first expressvpn is an
app I use to stay secure online why
should you care about encrypting your
data well it's often easy for a hacker
to bypass Wi-Fi security and steal your
information they can exploit flaws like
crack that be crack with a K in case you
want to google it and check it out it's
hard to know whether your device or
network is vulnerable if you ever use
Wi-Fi at a hotel or a shopping mall you
are sending data over an open network
meaning no encryption at all which is
not the smart thing to do there are too
many people looking for your data I know
I've been hacked before it's no fun the
best way to ensure that all of your data
is encrypted and can't be read by
hackers
just use Express at VPN all you need to
do is download the Express VPN app on
your computer or smartphone you tap one
button to secure 100% of your network
data and then use the internet just the
way you normally would Express VPN is
incredibly reliable it's the fastest VPN
service I've tried they're also rated
the world's number one VPN provider by
review sites like TechRadar and sina
expressvpn takes privacy and security to
the next level
I love expressvpn you will too if you
want the best in online security and
privacy protection head over to express
VPN comm slash button for three extra
months free with the one-year package
protect your internet today with the VPN
I trust to keep my data safe go to
expressvpn comm slash bending get
started in your book you deal a lot with
the question of meaning and I have a lot
of friends who are who are scientists
ranging from the religious to to the
irreligious and I will say that my
irreligious friends and the agnostic or
atheistic friends who are scientists
look for meaning in in science itself
and I've always found this a little bit
puzzling on a materialistic level Why
should there be meaning in
agglomerations of atoms or in
evolutionarily beneficial adaptations
well where is the meaning to be found in
that yes so let me let me adjust
something you said in your in your
question you're saying that scientists
are looking for meaning your personal
level on a person sure but it's that the
number of letters in this book these are
letters from people who wrote to me when
especially during a period of time when
my email address was publicly accessible
but over that interval people had access
to me after it typically in response to
some appearance I made or on TV or even
in a in a public venue and I'm intrigued
by how many people were in search of
meaning and so it's not like I am
putting that in this no not now they are
making that happen
by their inquiries and personally I'm I
don't look for meaning I think it's
maybe that's okay for some people but
those who look for meaning typically it
comes with some assumption that oh
there's the meaning it's behind the
chair
okay or under a rock or or behind a tree
it implies that meaning is something out
there that you search for and then may
one day find and that's not personally
it's not how I think of meaning and I I
capture this fact in my replies to so
many of these letters for me meaning is
something you create you have the power
to create meaning in your life and in
the lives of others can you lessen the
suffering of another person that creates
meaning it creates purpose
it creates mission for who you are and
what you might do in life so for me
meaning can involve other people yeah
are you raising your morale children are
you you a good spouse this all creates
meaning in addition there's what you
might do for yourself
so for me as an as an academic I care
that I learn something every day if a
day goes by I don't learn something
that's a wasted day I want to like go
back recapture the day and and rummage
through the books to find something and
ideally you should get your mind blown
at least once a week by just something
whoa I never knew that and so for me
that is where I get that is how I
establish and derive meaning in my life
so I mean maybe I should redefined the
term meaning I should be using the word
purpose which is which is word I like to
talk about a lot I think I mean I
totally agree in my book I talked about
you know the relationship between
meaning and purpose and I suggest that
people do have to have purpose in order
to find meaning I guess the question
remains that when you look to finding a
purpose why should we look into the
random assortment of guts or or the or
the evolutionarily beneficial firing of
neurons for purpose and does that how
does that relate to questions like
morality or the moral good what's
interesting about your set of questions
there is that there in at least half a
dozen letters rank written to me
there there there you are not alone in
that sentiment so I think it's not
obvious in just a cursory review of
science you'd think to yourself this is
dispassionate cold facts about the
universe the world nature that is not
where I'm turning if I gotta find
meaning in life however consider that
the atoms in your body were manufactured
in the cores of stars billions of years
ago stars that exploded if they didn't
these atoms would be locked away forever
they exploded scattering that enrichment
across the galaxy and out of that
enrichment forms planets life people and
so when you look up in the night sky if
you feel small and lonely it's a
knowledge that you're connected in this
way to the Stars that we are not just
figuratively we're literally Stardust
can give you a sense of belonging and
what might otherwise come across to you
as a cold and heartless universe it is a
beautiful idea and a beautiful sense me
I know Michael Shermer is written a lot
about this this sort of belief as well
in your book and in your other writings
you've talked about you know the the
application of science to questions of
morality and I guess the the question
one that I have when I hear something
like that is that's a romantic way of
putting the idea that we're meatballs in
space were Spinoza's stone that sort of
thrown and then we have this bizarre
awareness that we've been thrown but
there's nothing we can do about it I am
you are the first ever talk show host to
mention Spinoza yeah well thank you I
guess very much Jewish philosopher right
exactly exactly and probably mm+
pantheist maybe the first open atheist
yeah exactly right but first a long
tradition of atheist Jews yeah I mean we
can argue about have a great how great
it is but Martha's metric
didn't end great but in any case when we
when we talk about you know that that
particular moral question or the
purpose-driven question in your book you
talk about how you think a moral system
can be derived from science and you sort
of assume that moral systems the
thriving of humans the same way that Sam
Harris or Michael Shermer talks about it
that that is sort of a given and that we
all defined thriving in the same way and
you're very critical obviously of
judeo-christian religion particularly
well known I wouldn't put it that way I
would say if you're trying to fight me
using judeo-christian religious texts if
you try to fight me about the nature of
the physical universe that's it
otherwise I'm not gonna if Jesus is your
savior if Moses is your man I'm not
taking that away from you I have no
intentions on taking that away from you
there there are letters in here from
from Jews from Muslims but this Buddhist
wrote in and the the corpus of those
where people like to sort of tussle with
religion tend to be fundamentalist
Christians so there's a chunk of letters
in there as well but each of them have a
different reason for coming to me and so
the conversation is different one of
them says is there any way the universe
can be 6,000 years old
it's just please help me out here I want
to try to get bit and as you know 6,000
years is the canonical biblical age if
you run through the begats of Genesis
and the begats in Genesis what yes thank
you there thank you so I don't think
science hanzou morality but I think
science informs morality and that's an
important connection that I don't think
people commonly make today there's a lot
to know about life about you know people
debating abortion people debating issues
related to human physiology and health
who
well what do you know about the nervous
system what do we know about a
consciousness what do we know about you
know we in the brain the neurological
neuro synaptic connections if a part of
this brain gets damaged you don't even
know who you are if another part gets
damaged you can't speak another game
stammers you can't recognize a face and
that's kind of important information
about how we're gonna handle what
happens to people right now you can have
your your your your morality panels or
whatever they're called you know the
people who who advise politicians or
whatever ethics ethics right right right
and so but don't believe that a
scientist shouldn't be in that room no I
certainly believe that scientists should
be in the room to provide the additional
information necessary to to fill out the
application of moral principles I guess
I guess that my question becomes when
we're talking about the original
initiation of moral principle why should
we believe that science can do that I
bought never said that but I think that
there's a very strong David Hume is our
problem well yeah except if you look at
what we consider to be moral principles
today it is especially in communities
where they say we have judeo-christian
foundations for society there's a lot of
editing our share of what went on in the
Bible versus what we value and judge
today and so you can ask what is the
foundation of the editing and this
really is traceable to secular
discussion about our understanding about
civilization about people about how we
treat each other one another and so you
know when you look at Darwin and learn
of course there are people social
Darwinist which fed Nazism right and and
and eugenics but you'd be parked through
those curtains at the bottom of Darwin
is the fact that we are all genetically
connected that's profound
it means we have different skin color
but we are
fundamentally identical as a species
okay and you know to a jellyfish they
will not be able to tell us apart if
you're a jellyfish
so the commonality of DNA among all
humans the commonality of dma DNA among
all life on Earth that is stupefying
that has value and the is in the art
question I don't have a problem with
that as a starting place but generally
people who come at it from an is and a
not in other words science can tell you
what is true but they can't tell you
what should be right with just a
paraphrase yes Vince I think they both
still have to happen together so we're
talking about how to construct a
morality or how to live within a moral
system and you suggested I think rightly
that the the effect of Reason on
religious principle as inherited over
time has purified many of those
principles and made the different smells
better made for a better world I totally
agree with that obviously I believe that
there the way that I've put it with
regard to civilization myself is that
civilization is a suspension bridge
basically between a pole that is certain
fundamental assume premises that can't
be proved by science and then science
and reason and the fact is that where I
start to get a little afraid is if the
pull of science and reason begins to
believe that it is self-perpetuating and
we lose some of the fundamental
principles so the example that I would
give is you mentioned Darwinism before
the it is perfectly plausible and in
fact fairly easy to read social
Darwinism into Darwinism and people did
for several generations yeah right and
so now the same generation exactly is it
so now we say okay that that never
should have happened obviously that's
wrong that's a bad read of Darwinism
there's no reason you have to read
evolution to suggest that we should
benefit certain people at the expense of
other people but that is a moral reading
of Darwin not a not a reading of Darwin
that is inherent in Darwin itself that
is bringing premises that actually
pre-exists Darwin to bear on that if
properly
it's bringing bias right which human it
sounds highly susceptible to and
especially in the social sciences so
there's less bias in the sciences that
don't involve human behavior you can
start by there's less of it and it has
and the consequences are less dire if
anything that happens becomes policy and
so that's the digested analysis of what
came out of out of Darwinism but yeah
yeah so I think the reason that this
comes up is there is one sweet Lisa and
of course I'm sure you know where I'm
going with this there's this one sweet
the scent that drew an enormous amount
of ire on particularly the right about
ration Elia that you are looking forward
to the aroma Russian are yeah yeah yeah
what so first of all what would ration
Elia so this is the for those who missed
the tweet they suggestions was really
for year three years ago now yeah no it
was but it was a fascinating
conversation because it began this whole
kind of discussion about what a well
governed system would look like or who
would govern that system and so I don't
want to miss what exactly you were
saying this why don't you why don't you
suggest it so I don't misquote you to
clarify I was at a conference in the
Canary Islands and there was a
conversation I walked into during the
cocktail hour and there was already buzz
it involved a woman whose name I forgot
but I mentioned her name in my facebook
note that expands on the rationale yeah
tweet and she had the idea of having a
place whole rational land okay and I
said no we got do get need a better name
the rational and so rationality yes
right of Somalia sir you know and the
premise in this room of people this is a
conference of scientists and artists
actually was that imagine a community it
could be virtual doesn't have to have
geographic boundaries where all laws are
created only on the strength of evidence
in support of them period all laws now
if you
think about that that's cut that has
very sound principles because in
especially in America murca
we've got a diversity of cultures
religions other kinds of belief systems
and we're technically supposed to
celebrate that EEP lura brisk unum right
many is one or one is many right out of
line one thank you and so you applied to
let me figure it out very polite of you
so so in such a place if I had some
belief system based on my religion or
culture or whatever and I rise to
political power and I want to make a law
the laws apply to everyone in the land
but if that law derives from my belief
system and now I force others into that
law that's a recipe for disaster that is
that is how to guarantee an unstable
culture unstable civilization it
destabilizes civilization so the idea is
any law that applies to everybody needs
to be based on some objective truths and
how do you establish objective truths
the best way we know is by the methods
and tools of science and the strength of
the law would be commensurate with the
strength of the evidence to support it
and if you don't have the evidence that
support it you have no business making a
law for it so that would be the premise
and then some people jumped in in the
doctor I don't read everyone you
probably don't either cuz you know talk
about pissing off the internet your king
of drag me into this so so how would how
would this work so the a lot of the
debates centered on well who's going to
decide what's true enough to base a law
on and other people didn't see my actual
words there's a lot of reading
comprehension is
I've noticed I said objective truth and
people read that as absolute truth
mm-hmm and that's not the word I used
then people said who's to decide what is
absolute read there's no such thing as
an absolute truth and I never said that
right and there's a difference
I might convince there's an absolute
truth the science establishes what is
true based on evidence and that seems to
work but there could be later evidence
that gets to a deeper truth and we're
open to that that's how we went from
Newton to Einstein right Newton still
works
you see you took physics for sure those
quick you still use Newton's equations
but there are situations where they
don't apply they break down and you need
a bigger story so in comes Einstein
draws a bigger circle around the
Newtonian physics and so now I say is a
deeper understanding of the universe but
it doesn't negate Newton in this in the
regime in which it had previously
applied it still applies I was gonna
jump in and continue but people it got
very well you have a life to live I want
to eat so but I'm glad it's it
introduced some kind of thinking about
what role what kinds of forces should
operate on laws that we all must obey so
I think that there were two well-founded
Krita said they were a lot of poorly
found criticism I think they were too
well-founded critiques I should say
their letters in this book that are
asking about morality
right they come from a religious they
don't make a big deal of what religion
they're from generally they're Christian
but they want to have a sort of secular
conversation yeah the book is great by
the way come through it from a religious
background but they just want to find
out what science where science come from
and just and I'm what I want to hear the
rest of your question but I just want to
say that these letters these are people
who want to have the conversation yeah
there are plenty who just don't never
see those letters listen as a religious
person who is constantly discussing
issues in the public eye I won't cite
the Bible as proof of positions I don't
think that that is a valuable source in
terms of being able to discuss with
people it's in an appeal to Authority
that
if huge number of people don't accept I
mean that's no better than just citing
any other random person on the street
for a lot of fun what difference does
that make
but I think that when it came to the the
ration Elliot tweet there were two
critiques that I saw that were that I
thought were interesting so one was that
the question isn't should we bring the
best data to bear when making a law like
everybody who has any shred of
rationality should of course want the
best data to be brought to bear the
question when we make a law is one of
competing values meaning you're assuming
that everybody has the same ends in mind
and that isn't always the case so to
take an obvious example let's say that
there were evidence that removing all
guns in the United States with lower
violent crime in the United States so do
you remove all guns from people in the
United States that is actually a
question of values not purely a question
of whether a law would be effective in
issuing a particular ed because the end
itself is one of the questions do you
want a society where no one has the
capacity to protect themselves against a
tyrannical government for example so I
would say that the as posed that makes
complete sense that's not how I would
have posed it the way you posed it is is
there something you want as a society to
turn into law what would that be okay
and then you would test to see whether
that will fulfill your objectives if it
will fulfill your objectives then you
put it into law that's how you do this
you don't say I want to get rid of all
guns let's make it a law no you ask
collectively in a democracy the Republic
in which we live you ask what are your
goals is your goal to have fewer people
die from guns is that the goal how would
we accomplish this goal and then you do
the research and you find out oh you can
have biometric handles it leads my hand
my handprint so my gun is my gun you
steal my gun you can't use it that that
solves that problem okay
you don't want that problem solved you
have the right to do that as a citizen
in a democracy you say I don't want that
that I don't think that's a problem
let's not bring that to a law that's the
only point here the law is is to capture
to either support or deny something you
want to put into effect as a law the
other question that I saw wasn't the
sort of application of this principle so
this has been used over the course of
the 20th century particularly to move
the system of American government away
from a legislative lead system of
government toward a torta bureaucratic
system of government where an enormous
amount of regulation and rulemaking is
made by executive agencies purportedly
by experts and and one of the problems
there is that a lot of these places
become subject to regulatory capture
there's an evolution what is regulatory
regulatory capture means that you have a
lobbying groups for example to get a
hold of the EPA and now are making it
and now the bureaucrats who are largely
unassailable by the legislature and the
executive attention zone that sounds
like it is things happening in the world
that affect us all that are not derived
from objectively researched right I'm
asked about the implementation of your
principle I'm a natural particular level
meaning we're just talking in a utopian
world or is there a way to actually
that's a great question then yeah I
didn't know where you're going on yeah
so so we have agencies that are entirely
tasks with finding out what is
objectively true leading among them and
by the way a lot of the cross tweets
were saying yeah we the this is the
Department of truth or whatever you know
in in Georgia or well or or the 1984 oh
yeah 1984 or in Nazi Germany who didn't
they actually have a bureau of
propaganda literally Glenn Beck nervous
yeah yeah I think they even called it
but it's not right so the National
Academy of Sciences which was signed
into law signed into created under the
leadership of America's first Republican
president who you know that is who's in
it
nurse Republican presidents Lincoln
Lincoln exactly 1863 when
had other things he needed to work 53
there he signed the National Academy of
Sciences because Europe was riding high
economic Lee scientifically from an
engineering point they were fully
exploiting the fruits of the Industrial
Revolution and they were kind of slowly
working their way across the pond back
here to the United States he said I we
got a we have to get into that so the
National Academy of Sciences has one job
one job and that is to report on what is
objectively true in the scientific
fields in ways that can inform policy at
the executive branch and in the
legislative branch that's their job so
when they come out with a report they
have reviewed all the evidence all and
if they can't arrive at a conclusion
they'll tell you that the evidence is
inconclusive evidence is conclusive this
is where these know you can do whatever
you want with your policy because it's
not ration area you still have lawmakers
who have who are who are responsive to a
constituency to lobbyists and the like
but don't tell me you don't have the
evidence there to base it on and so so
you would glorify you would enhance the
importance and significance of a
National Academy of Sciences so that you
wouldn't have small groups with non
representative belief systems taking
over the whole country's conduct so
let's talk about the scientific
processes is currently carried out in
the United States one of the things that
I'm afraid of and I see it from the
right on certain issues and from the
left on certain issues is a fear of
actually investigating certain areas of
science so on the right obviously people
typically cite climate change here and
say well you know the right is refuses
to acknowledge the climate change is
even happening or at least so large
swaths of the right refuse to
acknowledge that climate change is even
happening and I won't tropiclean
tropically a federated climate change
the climate change yes so most radicals
will say it's not even happening at all
that this is just part of a general
warming trend and or that it has stopped
or any of that but why don't we start
with with that and then we'll get to
sort of areas on the left where where
science has been politicized or where
maybe an inquiry has been limited no or
attempted to be limited so on the
climate change will hard direct more hot
yeah so so so let's talk about the
climate change issue for a second so
what do we know and what is uncertain
because this seems to be there there are
it seems to me gray areas but the gray
areas are baked into the science meaning
that according to the IPCC report the
climate could warm anywhere from two
degrees Celsius to six degrees Celsius
over the course of the next century or
so we're still not sure exactly of the
level of climate sensitivity to human
activity you can acknowledge that human
activity is responsible for the majority
to the vast majority of climate change
that has happened on earth for the past
century or so the dust rule age right
exactly but what is the range of
outcomes and does that suggest that if
you have a different point of view on
the solutions that this amounts to
climate denial that's the part that I
start to get dicey about yeah
so I I mean professionally I'm an
astrophysicist and not a climate sign
right but I do read and I do recognize
when a scientific consensus emerges and
I want to make it clear what I mean by
the word consensus akan scientific
consensus is one it's not where everyone
gets to the rumor says hey let's vote so
that's not how truth is established it's
established by looking at peer-reviewed
research and asking and what direction
is that taking us what is it saying and
not any one research paper has all
answers in it they're like pieces of
answers and I looked at this I score in
this section of Greenland well I looked
in an ice core in Antarctica going back
a hundred thousand years well I looked
at the the migration patterns of this
insect and you start piecing together
the biology the chemistry the geology
the atmosphere of science and it's all
pointing in the same direction when that
happens it's time to sit up and take
notice what the hell is going on okay
and when we speak of a climate consensus
what we're saying is that the
overwhelming majority of the scientific
community has produced research evidence
citing that humans are responsible for
climate changing in this world leading
to the warming of temperatures in the
atmosphere period if you want to deny
that you are denying it because it
object it conflicts with your cultural
or political principles okay it's a free
country go ahead and do so but if you
now rise to power over legislation
that's dangerous it's irresponsible and
dangerous so the challenges are modeling
climate oh my gosh it's like there's the
heating of the oceans from that Sun and
then the oceans keep some of the heat
and they trapa tigue put it low so then
when the atmosphere cools the ocean
releases some of that heat back and then
and the trees and that the ice caps
reflect sunlight back but if they shrink
then it but it's more so there's a
there's a lot it's a hundred stuff so
that's why there's variance in the
predictions that come from it but the
predictions
all point in the same general direction
you will never have 100% of all
scientists agreeing that's not how
progress in science works it's the what
you're looking for is the overwhelming
it was only half the scientific papers
showed this and the other half didn't
you got no result I guess the question
that I have about climate change and at
least it's public facing sort of
presentation is the level of uncertainty
when it comes to its effect so you can
acknowledge that climate change is
happening there are people who talk
about catastrophic climate change
millions of migrants suddenly running
around the world Miami underwater yeah
we're all we're all dead within a
century and a half is there a certain
catastrophic model we will not all be
dead in a century of that no and
immortal our coastlines well and and by
flooding all our coastlines it's not
going to be immediate you mean that
there will be a gradual increase in in
sea level however which can be mitigated
in certain ways probably Howard
yes consider that most of the world's
most important cities are on the water's
edge historically for transportation for
Commerce and the like the most important
cities in the world are on the order
okay most of the most important cities
in the world are found in that way all
right so it's not like the water level
start to rise you might if you're
following my tweets I said if we lose
the if we lose the Greenland ice sheet
and the Antarctic Ice Sheet
then all that water goes back into the
ocean the ocean levels will rise it'll
rise to the level of the Statue of
Liberty's left elbow yeah what are the
chances that the entire Greenland ice
sheet case it's the limit an asteroid
where to hit the earth we'd all be dead
but yes no but it's if you want to ask
how bad could it get that's how bad it
could get and just just to give her
elbows straight she's holding the
Declaration of Independence left this
that oh so I mean but this is one of the
the areas where I feel like okay so why
are we talking about the limiting case
as opposed to most likely case or the
the cases that are most likely to fall
within the range of possibility and is
that sort of alarmism generated
generative of bad thinking about
possible solutions meaning that during
the dinosaurs during periods of when the
dinosaurs roamed there was no ice on
earth and so it was much less land when
you enter an ice age water evaporates
from the oceans it goes up to clouds the
clouds move over land it snows but it's
so cold the snow never melts it just
stays there and this just keeps
happening
so you're systematically draining the
ocean and you're building snow layers on
the ground on land masses these are
glaciers glaciers are slow-moving
and they're very they'll slowly go back
to the ocean but but slower than the
rate at which the oceans are being
drained
that's what revealed the Bering Strait
land bridge to our nomadic ancestors
said hey let's keep walking
you just keep boring it's just LAN this
key and they walk into North America the
the Ice Age ends it melts the water
levels rise the Lambeth bridge is broken
and never the twain would meet for tens
of thousands of years
stranding an entire branch of the human
species in North and South America by
the way this which is why the Columbus
voyage was in my read of history the
single most important thing that ever
happened in civilization if it wasn't
him it would have been someone else but
it happened to be him he reconnected
these two separate branches of the human
species that had been separated for ten
thousand tens of thousands of years
that's a profound fact for me
so we it's already been the case that
the earth had known ice had a lot of ice
right so this is not like and we've
already been hit by an asteroid okay you
can say all asteroid as I tell that to
the dinosaurs right the dead dinosaurs
who didn't have a space program for
opposable thumbs oh hey both so so the
issue is not that the water level will
rise and you can just walk away from it
it's it rises this much and the next
storm surge combined with a high tide
which you almost always get with a
hurricane because it takes a long time
for a hurricane to move up the coast it
takes typically a couple of weeks
somewhere in there there's going to be
full moon or new moon high tide with a
storm surge suppose your your your your
jetties or levees or whatever it is that
keeps your city safe from the water
that's out right there in the river or
in the bay or in the ocean whatever that
height is is what you decided would be
what would protect the city right the
ocean goes up an inch that's all it
takes
one inch to breach your your levees if
you reach you by one inch your city is
now connected to a semi infinite amount
of water for as long as that hurricane
is sitting there and the water just
pours in that's what happened here in
hurricane sandy Katrina's already
breached all the levees yeah well
Lenny's broke don't get me started
that was like engineering I mean that
Katrina was category three it already
passed through New Orleans people were
like sweeping up the branches okay we
got we can ride that then the levees
broke okay so the broken levees flooded
New Orleans not Katrina we keep blaming
Katrina without putting the lens back on
our own maintenance of our
infrastructure and our anticipation of
what could happen given certain forces
of nature my point is you're gonna flood
your city not because the water will
slowly rise
you're gonna flood your city because the
storm that has the benefit of that extra
inch plus a storm surge plus a higher
intensity of the storm because if the
atmosphere is warmer it carries more
moisture there's more heat driving the
intensity of storms you breach that
you'll flood the city and there you have
it or you lose your beach house
it happens in those storms that's your
first indication that your coastline is
at risk and not to mention those
countries island countries in the South
Pacific where the average elevation is a
few feet above sea level so you talked
about refugees you know who knows about
global warming and was preparing for it
insurance companies and the military the
military cares
our military cares about where there is
unrest in the world where if people are
displaced that creates problems because
they got to go somewhere and the borders
are closed or unless you're near a nice
country right so so yeah this is it
affects more than just your beach house
for sure I mean the question becomes
whether mitigation is the is the chief
method of fighting this or adaptation is
the chief method of fighting this or
geoengineering should we be building
more levees engineering technologies
help it's in its infancy geoengineering
but for me one one pie in the sky
thought I have is hurricanes coming to
ready to destroy a city you put in some
big anemometer inside the hurricane
right and it spins the anemometer but
the anemometer is itself
turbine right so it's sucking energy
from the cyclonic motion of the
hurricane and you use that to drive the
energy needs of the city that it might
have allies this work you should propose
that to President Draghi so moving on
from from climate change which is an
area as I said where some people on the
right are not particularly interested to
areas where it seems like the left is
militating against the the advent of
science one of those areas is the area
of transgenderism where the argument
namely there's no chant Trent no I have
no transgender letters it's true it was
just nothing in the book and that's no
one it's straight now far from the topic
of your book but since I have you here
in you're a science person who knows
science I'm gonna ask you to science for
me a little bit but when it comes to
transgenderism the the argument that is
typically made by gender theorists is
that gender is entirely separate from
sex you've seen the argument made that
it makes no difference on average if men
are stronger than women are and that if
we were to allow transgender women to
compete with non transgendered women
then this would somehow not disadvantage
biological women and this seems to me
absolutely a scientific that if we're
actually going to have a discussion
about gender and sex that that should be
based in data which suggests that
mammals are in fact binary in terms of
their sex unless you have intersex birth
defects typically or genetic defects I'm
happy to opine on this this only matters
because today we segregate most nearly
all sports by gender otherwise why do
you even give us what's what someone
identifies with so this is we live in a
free country and with consenting adults
and people free expression of who and
what they are now an adult level I agree
with you I think it does matter what it
and so there's the there's the the
matrix of you know what you are
biologically how you express yourself
who you choose as a sexual partner if we
actually live in a free country as we
tell ourselves people's freedom to
behave in any of those ways should not
concern you at all nor are they
requiring that you behave that way okay
this is for their own freedoms well as
we live in a free country
now what is unresolved here is what do
you do with sports its unresolved and
I've followed that closely and I don't
see any I don't see any meaningful
solutions to come down off of that we
know that hormones manifest differently
in different people and does the whole
thing with steroids steroids are
hormones right and we rallied against
steroids in professional sports because
it gives you an undue advantage so I'd
have tried to think of what the future
of sports would be in the world of a
gender spectrum and it may be you don't
specify whether it's a male or female
sport you just take measurements of what
your hormonal balances are and so you
compete based on oh I don't know where
it's gonna land
WNBA won't be in business for very long
if that's the case it would just be
you'd have to you'd have to find some
way to compete people against each other
if you still care that sports is an
interesting activity
I guess the area where it does come up
in a non sports area so it would be you
talk in your book about the education of
children and teaching children about
science and right now children are being
taught about the quote unquote gender
spectrum which is not scientifically
based that is a that is a theory based
idea people express themselves on a
spectrum so you learn that that's that's
that that's it that's a social that's so
some point not a scientific point it's
its meaning we express ourselves in
based in different languages that's
something you teach in science
classrooms that's something that you
teach when you're teaching language so
whether the fact that people want to
express themselves on a spectrum on a
gender spectrum
whether that fact is something you want
to put in a sociology class or in a
science class
maybe that remains to be determined but
it is a real fact about real society of
course nobody's denying that people
identify how they want to identify so so
so question is what is the relationship
of that to biology meaning that the
argument is made that trans women are
women for example and what that seems to
mean is that trans women are identical
to it now people want to say trans women
are not biological women obviously that
is the case but people don't seem to
want to say that although that is
obviously scientifically true trans
women are not biological women
biological women are biological women
but where are you going with this what
what is your what is your what are you
trying to accomplish by asking yourself
is it science or is it not science it's
how it's people in society but this is
this is a perfect example of an area
where suddenly it doesn't matter to say
things that are just true like why is it
why is it bad or wrong okay I have
another way to to approach this I care
what is objectively true in the world as
a scientist but let me not say even as a
scientist I just simply care what is
objectively true and science happens to
be a pretty potent path to invoke to
find out what is true and so if people
express themselves on a gender spectrum
and that is an actual thing in an actual
society if we have not fully explained
that scientifically that's an
interesting frontier to study if you
want to say it's only sociological then
it's the purview of the social sciences
I don't care who studies it it's an
interesting fact about society that's
worth learning about it to make it to
fight someone to say it's not biological
it's just your dissident it's real and
it's there
well because it's real because it
manifests it is real because now it
manifests but the question of the how to
classify manifestation
is a scientific question meaning that
for example there's there's a woman over
at Brown University she came out with a
study that suggested that there was a
phenomenon called the rapid onset gender
dysphoria in which a member of a
particular group would suffer from
gender dysphoria and this person
immediate peer group would suddenly have
an onset of gender dysphoria this paper
was so controversial that Brown tried to
pull it and then was was forced to read
reassign it later you see this sort of
question what you're asking now is are
there some topics that should not be
studied scientifically right and is
there some taboo I'm sam harris speaks a
lot about this yes and i think the
concern is if you study some topic
that's a hot-button topic and you bring
scientific methods and tools to it there
we don't trust i'm interpreting here i
think we as a society don't trust that
people in charge in a free country won't
try to legislate something that will
constrict people's freedoms in the face
of that information I think that's the
fear
well isn't that it's a fear I mean and
isn't that don't trust our own ability
to govern ourselves in the face of what
could be some information relative to
other what other countries isn't that a
bit of a problem yeah yeah yeah it's not
it means it's not a free society it's
not a society of free inquiry which I
think you need ultimately but yeah my
general take on all of this stuff
climate change - gender dysphoria - all
these issues is bring out the science
and then let's hash it out I think that
the problem I'm seeing a lot of sighs
what is your motivation what why why
does that matter it matters because if
you have political power you could end
up creating legislation that subtracts
freedoms from people who previously were
enjoying the same freedoms as you the
history of that extra so make a better
argument and well yeah well but the
history of which exercise bring out all
the science and let's hash it out I'm
saying if you bring all the science and
the politicians hash it out the history
of that exercise was a recipe
for disaster if it involves discoveries
that put people's freedom as defined in
our Constitution at risk but now you're
arguing for limitations on areas of
particular study no I'm arguing on we
need a way to shield we need a way to
protect people's freedoms in the face of
whatever gets discovered scientifically
so I agree I think that's what the
Constitution is for is to guard rights
from always lying because people who
want rights are always fighting others
who are saying they don't get the rights
from the Constitution this is a daily
challenge on the progressive left is a
daily challenge right here's an example
I was I forgot how I ended up getting
this phone call it was some magazine
that serves the gay community and they
want item my because they won in my
opinion on there was some did one of my
opinion about whether being gay was
biological or there's that new study
that came out in Psychological right
okay right and I said I don't care which
it is it find out what it is fine but
the answer to that question should have
no consequence on legislations or laws
because for example suppose it's suppose
it said it's purely biological okay then
you say oh that explains it that poster
says it's purely psychological what are
you going to do now yeah well now you
can you know go to the the the the re
orientation camps or whatever those are
called where they realign you because
they say it's psychological rather than
biological all of a sudden people start
behaving in ways in society that want to
constrict the freedom of expression of
who and what people are and that is a
danger so maybe there needs to be a line
in the sand let science do what it does
but politicians keep us free yet there's
many politicians that are doing the
opposite of it so why are you
libertarian I'm a libertarian come over
here just okay the line is right here
join me over here I've read a lot about
libertarianism there's some fascinating
strong points within it but I would say
that I I have too much of me wants to
help others possibly cross over the law
and libertarians libertate I got mine
you get yours that's your problem
you know I'm paraphrasing the earth but
I might parents where my father was
active in the civil rights movement my
mother went back to school when we were
empty nest and she became a
gerontologist these are two fields that
deeply are deeply concerned with the
health and well-being of fellow members
of our society I grew up in that I'm
their kid the astrophysicist so I grew
up in that but I my feet were grounded
yeah and in fact how do you like this
pivot you ready in fact I wrote a letter
to my parents for their 30th wedding
anniversary where I thank to them for
keeping me grounded and it's I've
reproduced that letter oh yeah it's
beautiful it's in the book really is
fantastic I'm not just saying that it
really is a beautiful book so if you
read that you will you will know I could
never be liberal Fulop libertarian see
ok so just because my fans will murder
me if I don't just point out
libertarians don't actually just want
people to start with the story yeah big
believers who well I do want to flee
people yes social fabric very important
taking care of people giving charity
very very poor so final scientific
question for you obviously we're doing
hot buttons here so it you know we have
to make sure that our click count is
high obviously else we're gonna write a
headline here in slavery book so let's
talk about abortion for a second so when
it comes to the scientific study of
fetal development there are people who
are militating against for example the
use of ultrasound techniques in
pregnancy clinics so Planned Parenthood
famously is objects to people using or
government-funded 3d ultrasounds before
an abortion and their suggestion is that
this is a violation of the freedom of
women now an abortion
what pro-lifers say is the science is is
fairly clear that the inception of life
happens at conception and then there's
fetal development all the way
continuously from point A basically to
death and so the attempts to draw
particular lines you can create little
developmental births they've healed not
once but many and then you continue
developing until you know there's my
fetal right okay fair enough
so so the question becomes on the
abortion case how much of that do you
think is values-driven and how much of
that's you that that debate do you think
is scientifically driven so let me I
think we would all welcome a world where
abortions are not necessary and so
everyone's focusing on abortion and not
focusing on contraception for example
and that to me that's a that's an
imbalanced I totally agree that's and
you also know there are people who are
anti-abortion and anti contraception and
that's I don't think the history of our
understanding of what it is to be human
can ever be reconciled with that fact
all right
sex is fundamental to to sexual
reproducing animals sex predates humans
by half a billion years so so it's to
try to legislate people to not have sex
may be simply unrealistic so you'd want
laws that reflect what is possible
rather than to force what may be
impossible culturally impossible so if
you want to have the abortion debate I
would ask how many people on who are
anti-abortion are anti-abortion and are
not simultaneously deeply religious
right so if there's a strong religious
component of those who want to ban
abortion that's an interesting fact
about the the demographics of what's
going on out there and so that's one
interesting fact
if you're concerned about what is alive
or what constitutes a human life because
obvious that mean that really is the
question what constitutes a human life
because obviously if it's just what's
alive then save the flies right yeah
sperm is alive right it swims right it
swims with a mission right so so you so
somebody has to say okay I care when
it's a human life all right so now we
have to what makes it human is it just
genetically human or is it do you need a
certain minimum neuron count to judge
well now it is 10 so I think that can be
debated just debate that and I'm I don't
have opinions that I require other
people agree with all right if you look
carefully at my Twitter stream rarely is
there an opinion right the last time I
remember posting an opinion it was the
enterprise or or the Millennium Falcon
okay and I did to a video where we
tussled it out what was the outcome of
that video oh definitely enterprise but
also I said bb-8 is way cuter than r2d2
that is an objective fact I just wanted
to know I agree so you see sea is
designed to be cute be cute and and r2d2
was cute in 1975 you need a modern
updated version of what cutest so is
whether abortions are legal or not just
a matter of majority vote in a society
is it you know these are questions that
people are debating I was I was content
for with whether a fetus is sustainable
outside of the womb as sort of a a
denying idea as a divide that made sense
to me when that was put forth to say
that it's a human when it's just a
fertilized embryo I don't I think most
people don't know particularly they're
religious most last
check these numbers most fertilized eggs
Vietnam women are spontaneously aborted
the body rejects most of the times there
is conception and so so what do you do
about that or do you want to create a a
an incubation chamber so that every
spontaneously aborted fertilized egg
gets put in there and grows to a human
otherwise the you you'll get arrested
for murder so they're by the way this is
science informing the debate right so so
I don't know where this is gonna land
and I don't I don't have opinions that I
require other people agree with okay so
I do have one final question for Neil
deGrasse Tyson and that is I'm going to
ask him for his favorite science fiction
movies and also the ones that are the
worst when it comes to the science but
if you actually want to hear neil
degrasse tyson's answer you have to be a
daily water subscriber so we can make
money off of you to subscribe go to
daily we're calm and click Subscribe
Neil deGrasse Tyson the book is letters
from an astrophysicist go pick it up
right now it really is fantastic Neil
thank you so much for your time
delighted thanks for having
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show Sunday special is
directed by Mathis Glover and produced
by Jonathan hey executive producer
Jeremy boring associate producer Colton
Haas our guests are booked by Kaitlyn
Manor post-production is supervised by
Alex Singaram editing by Donovan Fowler
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jesuit alvera pedal
graphics by Cynthia Angulo the Ben
Shapiro show Sunday special is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20